Fabienne Larouche, bonsoir.
- Bonsoir, Patrice.
- Vous n'aviez impliquant, vousi
n'en peut plus qui vous a appelé
et qui a dit : Fabienne, fau
qu'on arrête.puis depuis le
mois de septembre commences à
parler de ça, à partager ça, et
la décision a été prise autour
du mois d'octobre, j'ai
leur dire : voici a
arriver, c'est la dernière année
de District 31. On a vouluer au,
comme vous y visiez
réguliè millions qui
nous écoutent à tous les soirs,
quatre soirs semaine, pour ne
pas que le 21 avril, c'est comme
ça, c'est la fin de districtpou,
quand on apprend que c'est laafn
a du plaisir, reste encore 55
à écoutez, et puis la
fin va être magnifique.
- On l'imagine, est-ce que vous
d'autres auteurs que le Dionnepu
c'est impossible dans votre
esprit?
- Impossible. D'abord que je
suis un auteur moi
Luc a éten
sûr, mais de talent, il a son
propre langage, et ça, ça nepeuz
un autre auteur ou quelqu'un
d'autre,
District, ça a été incroyabl
une aventure incroyable pour,
Michelle et moi, mais aussi,
l'une était supportée par un
groupe d'acteurs hyper doués,
une équipe technique désire que
c'est quand tout le monde queere
l'affaire, alors ça donne ça.
Mais je
l'ai vécu pendant 20 que c'est
que de grands plaisirs mais de
décès de Jean-Marc Vallée,
ans, j'en ai 63, on s'est dit :à
autre chose, puis aussi, c'est
notre métier à nous, les
auteurs, de créer des univers ùu
les histoires naissent, vivent
et se terminent. Il est déjà
rendu ailleurs.- On parlait d'u,
DPCP, Radio-Canada. Est-ce queit
arrivé, je le disais, c'est un
phénomè
difficile à reproduire. Est-ce
e
autre quotidienne lettre dès
l'an prochain?
C'est une très bonne question.
Je viens de vous dire que je
suis peut-être re
flambeau, puis à en aider
d'autres, des prod
créateurs. Une job deienne que a
peut peut-être faire mon
affaire. Il y a un temps où il
faut passer le flambeau.
- Vous n'allez pas produire une
autre quotidienne pour Radio-
Canada l'an prochain.
- Pfff...
Je ne pe
parce qu pas clair pas clair pa.
C'est compliqué Patrice, ça étét
quand même 26 ans... Michel me
disait... tu as écrit et on a
écrit de Virginie, 30,6 ans de,,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait? Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait? Qu'est-ce qu'on va n
Floride.
- C'est pas totalement décidé,
mais de recréer à l'infini des
quotidie
machine, ce n'est pas simple
comme ça.
- Ça, c'est une tempête
parfaite, si je peux dire. Sarré
avec une équipe douée, avec des
producteurs qui essaient de
faire une belle jo
diffuseur, il ne faut pas
oublier que Radio-Canada a été
un soutien là-dedans, d'une
aide. Maintenant, on verra, tou,
ce que je vous ai dit, c'est que
je pourrnte,nte,nte,nte,nte,nte,
je veux dire, je peux en aider
d'autres.
- On a compris. Je